i'm harris faulkner i'm greg gutfeld i'm
janis dean
and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday december 30th 2020 i'm chris
foster it's a dark period of the
coronavirus pandemic but fox news
medical contributor dr marty mccary sees
a light at the end of the tunnel
i anticipate that we're going to
probably hit those herd immunity levels
in march
and that april will will be the month of
massive deceleration
of the infection i'm dave anthony
today we look back to a time before
covid was a pandemic
our first glimpse at life in lockdown in
china little did we know then we would
be
living it here biggest concern is food
shortages
and civil unrest not not so much the
virus
and i'm cal thomas i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
335 000 coronavirus deaths have been
reported in the united states now
hospitalizations are at record highs
more than 121 000 currently
in california there are patients being
put intense conference rooms even gift
shops
governor gavin newsom says about some of
the nurses tending to twice as many
patients
as usual absolute expression of
admiration
respect for our nurses that are asked to
do more
with less staff and less support it's
heroic
meantime more people are getting
vaccinated including vice
president-elect kamala harris
thank you i barely felt it
i barely felt it but the number of doses
shipped to states has been lower than
projected and the goal of having 20
million people vaccinated by the end of
the month is not being met
we've had a lot of problems in the last
10 yards of the distribution
dr marty mccary is a professor of
surgery and health policy at johns
hopkins university and a fox news
medical contributor
that's for a lot of different reasons
one first of all the real world is
always more complex
than we'd like to think right the cdc
issued their guidance on who should get
it on december 20th i mean that's two
weeks after the vaccine was shipped
and that left hospitals scrambling as to
who should get it
it left states scrambling and so that
created a lot of confusion even in the
general public now people are wondering
where should you go and what should you
do so
that has been an issue it looks like
coming out of thanksgiving
we got some spikes related to to to
people visiting each other's homes
and not others now that we've just
passed christmas do you think that it
was just luck or better compliance in
certain areas or what are you worried
about a christmas fallout
well it's unclear if thanksgiving really
accelerated things because
we've seen a gradual increase through
thanksgiving and so the 10 to 15 percent
increase that we saw in most states
after thanksgiving in the three weeks
following
may have been the normal distribution
curve now it it also means that people
have not adopted good practices
as they should to really stop the spread
but right now we're starting to see a
plateau
and it's unclear if that plateau is
the sort of the peak of this number of
cases
or if it's just poor reporting from the
holidays which we traditionally see with
weekend reporting
i'm hoping that it is a true plateau and
i'm hoping that people have learned some
lessons you know people
are all sort of getting religion the
hard way they're hearing about somebody
you know it starts with my friend's dad
or
my you know grandmother tested positive
and then you know then if she has
symptoms
and then it's she's in the hospital and
then there's something unfortunate or
a close call or a tragedy that sort of
gets everybody on board so that's
happening to
families all over the country right now
and i think people are coming around
it's just unfortunate
how they're doing it tell me about the
mutated strains we're told they're more
contagious
but not more deadly is there a
scientific reason to worry the vaccines
won't handle them or whatever else
comes along well the current vaccines
appear to encompass the new mutated
strains but
i am very concerned about the new
mutated sprains strains because it means
that the velocity of transmission
is going to be a lot higher that is the
vaccine's going to be stickier
it's going to be more contagious and
it's going to rip through
society faster so that is a concern
but the current trajectory the rate of
mutations that we're seeing remember
first we saw some
in new york and the virus was a little
different from the virus that was in
seattle
and then we heard about a different
strain in europe and china
then we saw mutated strains in houston
that were a little more contagious
and so what this tells us now in the uk
where
where by the way six out of ten infected
people with covet have the mutated
strain in the uk
so it spreads quickly it's what we call
selective pressure that is
a more contagious strain will dominate
the population
faster and crowd out the other strains
it tells us that this thing is going to
continue to mutate
coronavirus is going to be with us for a
long time and
at some point it may mutate around the
current vaccine and that's why people
talk about maybe coming in for an
adjustment on the vaccine
sort of another vaccine shot every two
three or five years
like we do for seasonal flu yeah um
should the millions of people who've
been infected
need the vaccine or at least should they
get in the back of the line
i think they should get in the back of
the line and chris i think this is one
of the big messages that is not being
told
that needs to be told and that is if
you've had the infection if you've
tested positive or you've been confirmed
to have the antibodies with a reliable
test
get in the back of the vaccine line
because
natural immunity appears to work now i'm
going to be very honest with you
the old medical establishment belts and
suspenders professors are going to say
no we don't know that but we do know
that there's no formal studies but look
at the observational data
reinfection rates around the world have
been exceedingly rare
and when they do occur they're very mild
cases
and by the way the vaccine groups in the
trial five percent of them got the
infection
although mild cases so it's not like
vaccines perfect immunity either
natural immunity appears effective so if
you've had the infection step
in the back of the vaccine line for now
until we can study it further
can somebody who's been infected then
become an asymptomatic spreader do we
know
we don't know now it's a theoretical
possibility but if you think about how
your immune system
is immune it's basically triggered so
the second that identifies the virus in
your body
it attacks it swiftly so there's good
reason to believe once you've got
immunity
from a practical standpoint we're
probably good to go look we're not going
to going to eradicate viruses from
planet earth
and at some point we need to let people
live their lives yeah
um what's the status of a vaccine for
kids we have they even started testing
them yet
it's interesting that the pfizer vaccine
they
studied it in people over age 18 but
they applied for
use in kids who were 16 and 17 as well
and it created this big stir at the fda
and among the experts because
pfizer argued appropriately so that a 16
and 17
17 year old is physiologically
equivalent to an 18 year old
which is absolutely true but again the
old medical establishment says unless
you have the formal studies we're not
going to okay
so right now kids under 18 can only get
the moderna
vaccine which is approved for people
over sorry they only get the pfizer one
which is approved for over people over
16.
and the other studies are ongoing now in
kids 12 to 18.
the good news is kids really don't die
from covet 19 unless they have
comorbidities
yeah and i guess if if if enough
older people by older i mean 16 and up
get the vaccine then that should knock
down the virus enough that we don't have
to worry about the younger kids right
that's the herd immunity we're looking
for and it raises a good point chris
we don't need to vaccinate everybody to
really get a handle on this
in the spring assuming natural immunity
is good for at least a year or a couple
years
as it is by the way with the other
coronaviruses sars and mers
then we may only need to vaccinate 20 to
30 percent
to really start hitting that massive
slowing that we call herd immunity
and then in the interim we can go ahead
and get everyone who's not been
previously infected
or vaccinated the vaccine at that point
if you do the math we might be seeing
the start of a coronavirus baby boom
next month any advice for new or
breastfeeding moms as far as the vaccine
goes
is there any guidance there yeah i've
had forgotten about that baby boom
that's interesting so yeah i think right
now there's
every indication that the vaccine is
safe
you know even when kids have tested
positive or the moms have tested
positive
we've said that keep breastfeeding it's
probably
more important to breastfeed than it is
to try to
separate um people for concern
of the virus threat so everything
appears to be safe in pregnancy again
the formal tests have not been done so
the official answer from the medical
establishment is unknown
but nobody thinks that uh pregnancy is
significant risk
we've talked about these new antibody
treatments before
uh the operation warp speed people say
that something just like 20 percent of
the treatments that are in
hospital pharmacies are actually being
used is this is it a lack of interest a
lack of trust in it just a lack of
knowledge about them
it's a lack of awareness and it's also
um a little bit of i would put this on
the fda approval
they approved it for such a narrow
indication that it's very hard to give
it to people
in that specific indication which is
you're sick from covid and you're high
risk
but you have not yet come to the
hospital
okay well that's it's very hard to get
you know for us to identify those
individuals
so and then they have to be proactive to
go out there and tell their hospital or
their doctor hoping their doctor knows
hey i'd like to tap into that supply
that the hospital
has for sick coveted patients who are
high risk and not yet hospitalized
they should have made the indication
broader to allow it for
early infections among hospitalized
patients and that way we could have
given it to people
who come to the hospital sick who
benefit like president trump and chris
christie
that is the ideal place to give it but
again
the old professors of the medical
establishment and the fda have decided
to keep that indication so narrow and as
a result we have a lot sitting around
and there's poor awareness around it
and i bring up the awareness point
because people need to know also if
they're high risk and need the vaccine
you got to be your own advocate you got
to check that hospital website of your
local hospital frequently
check the website of cvs walgreens or
other large pharmacies in your area
and find out when they finally release
it to people in your category
yeah i mean people have to remember that
over the next weeks and months nobody's
going to knock on your door
with a with a syringe you're going to
have to take care of yourself
if you want the vaccine that's right you
got to be your own advocate
like with all things in healthcare you
got to be your own advocate all right
one more
i know there's not going to be a single
like national masks off go make out with
a stranger day
at any point next year but how do you
think it's going to work the timing of
when we can
burn the masks and stop the restrictions
on gatherings
is it just going to be place by place
and we'll take it as it comes well first
of all i'm going to give you a little
bit of a warning here
chris and that is i suspect that the
medical establishment will be
so painfully slow in rolling back the
mask
requirements that they may never
do it for all i know i mean coronavirus
is going to be with us for years to come
there's already four seasonal
coronaviruses this may just become the
fifth one
added to that group of coronaviruses
that circulate year to year
now it is good that if you think you've
been exposed if you have any symptoms at
any point in your future for the rest of
your life
wear a mask right that's something we
should have been doing asian cultures
have done it
we've not done it we're a little too
macho now we've learned our lesson
masks help in reducing seasonal flu
which were oddly complacent about the
number of deaths we've had each year
it's a good idea to wear masks if you
think you've been exposed to any virus
or if you have symptoms beyond that i
think we need to
start you know hugging each other and
and doing things without our masks and
have that personal connection
and i anticipate that we're going to
probably hit those herd immunity levels
in march
and that april will will be the month of
massive deceleration
of the infection and i i think i think
we're on track for that right now
all right from your mouth buddy i uh
that's nice to hear uh dr marty mccary's
a professor of surgery and health policy
at johns hopkins
he's fox news medical contributor he's
got a book out there called the price we
pay what broke american health care and
how to fix it
so the new york times best-selling
author and a favorite guest here on the
fox news rundown dr marty mccary thanks
a lot hey happy new year
you too happy new year chris great to be
with you
this is cal thomas with your fox news
commentary coming up
we really have lived through a lot in
2020
and this pandemic isn't close to being
over yet
a year ago at this time think back we
never even
heard of the coronavirus and then in
january
mysterious illnesses and deaths were
reported out of china
and then came the lockdown wuhan a city
many americans never heard of that has
more people than new york city was the
epicenter
and it was closed off so in late january
we tracked down an
american living and working there stuck
inside
dealing with something we couldn't
imagine not knowing we
would be living that same nightmare
unaware
how much worse it would get for us now
for me it's
one of the most memorable interviews i
did in 2020.
listen to the numbers of cases and
deaths
back then they seem like a lot now
it's an interesting snapshot of a time
when there were no masks here
and life was still normal in january
it's an outbreak that's hit china hard
and reached other countries too
including the u.s the corona virus
and the number of people infected grows
every day
thousands sickened more than a hundred
people have died
it has sealed off parts of china
transportation
halted including airlines like british
airways lufthansa and united
cancelling some flights to and from that
country now one plane
chartered by the state department did
fly 201 americans out of wuhan
the city at the epicenter of this
chinese outbreak
it landed on wednesday in riverside
california where
they'll be in quarantine just in case
even though they all passed health
screenings and were virus free
when they left wuhan we did submit our
personal information to try to get on
the flight i understand that some
families were offered seats and had
declined
we were not offered seats samuel roth
lives in wisconsin and is still in the
u.s
but his wife and two young daughters are
stuck
in wuhan you know they can put some
masks on and go outside
to walk to the grocery store and pick up
food
we're just trying to be vigilant that
everybody who goes in and out washes
their hands keep
the home clean and kill the virus if it
comes into the home
doug perez is another american who
is living through the nightmare in wuhan
where he's a teacher
in an english language immersion program
i'm with my girlfriend
her brother and our labrador chubby
chubby the apocalypse dog
so i've seen pictures of chubby he's
very cute
yeah uh he uh he's actually really
keeping us strong and
we're keeping each other strong and i'm
keeping in touch with all the other
americans here in wuhan and
we're supporting each other as much as
we can you know when we're feeling down
we text each other when we're worried we
text each other
you know i've had friends who break you
know broken down and you know we're
calling me crying and
we just we do what we can to keep each
other strong you can't really get
together with them can you or do
you do or do you just all text
all texts it's too dangerous for us to
to get together
and some of us are even sick maybe even
with the corona violet virus we don't
know but
we can only do so much via texting but
it's still incredibly powerful with
phone calls just
thank god for social media it keeps us
in touch with each other 24 7 in fact
it's a bit maddening
it's kind of too much contact with other
people uh
kind of ironically you know um but we've
just been
keeping contact 24 7 with each other you
know we have a
a network we're looking out for each
other and i think for
americans abroad really politics goes
right out the window
we're just looking out for each other we
just want everyone to be okay
you mentioned that some even might be
sick i mean if if any of your friends
or any of the americans you talk to
believe they
are are they going to go to a hospital
where do you go
now with it being such a problem and
wuhan where do you do
do you show up at a hospital that's out
of the question
hospitals are overrun even the
government made an official announcement
in you know in chinese saying that if
you have mild symptoms
mild symptoms if you're a little quote
unquote a little bit sick
do not come to the hospitals we're
overrun they need supplies
it's a disaster we our plan
and what those of us who are are sick we
stay in
we take aspirin and ibuprofen to control
the fever
and uh we just rest and eventually if
you're young and healthy
your body should be able to uh
you know do to stop the virus all right
so if you just let it run its course
then
so have you had these symptoms yourself
i i haven't had these symptoms or at
least not to this extent
i i don't believe i've had it uh no one
in my immediate
in my household here you know the three
of us we haven't had it but we have
friends who have all the symptoms and
some of them were running temperatures
before fortunately now they're not
running temperatures we're hoping
at least i'm hoping that they had it and
they recovered and
maybe they have some immunity to it now
but we don't know this is a completely
new virus even the scientists don't know
it's just brand new
right and my understanding is that more
than 100 people have died in china but
there are a lot of those people might
have had underlying
other health problems that the
coronavirus made worse that's true
in fact the median age is 65 and you
know the demographic has been hit
hardest the very old the very young and
those with health conditions and if you
have both
you're incredibly vulnerable to this
what scientists are concerned about is
if there's a mutation
and it could i spoke to a scientist here
who um
who was here during the stars outbreak
and i asked him could this mutate
and hit you know the younger demographic
part
and he he like he said to me you know
i'm not going to lie to you
very well you know sorry even even even
chubby's worried i can tell
it's scary i'll tell you a good story
about chubby though
i don't know if you saw we have a video
of it i'd be happy to send it to you but
at one point a couple days ago we all
everyone in wuhan
we went out to our windows and we were
all chanting
about wuhan you know yelling in chinese
we are all
wuhan people and come on wuhan
and it was very inspirational and chubby
heard us cheering and then he started
barking
do you get to take him everywhere you go
basically whenever we leave we bring the
dock so yeah we only take them out for
walks that's the extent
of us leaving if we the only other time
we left
was to gather food and stock up on
supplies we went out
we spent four or five hundred dollars on
groceries just
uh you know so that we can stock up and
be okay and that was a scary experience
too
guess what at the door to the uh
at the gate to the supermarket they're
checking everyone's temperature
everyone's temperature right there
before you even go into the store
before you even enter and this is
standard at supermarkets and walmart's
across wujon
so it's a pretty scary we're lining up
to be have our temperature tested
you know it was one of those temperature
guns they put to your forehead yeah it's
like something
uh it's like something out of a sci-fi
movie yeah
that must be a little unnerving now how
much did you you said you
spent four or five hundred dollars how
many days how many days of supplies was
that for you
i i would say if we really stretched it
out maybe three weeks to a month since
there's three of us
um you know we're all young and we eat a
lot and we have a dog too
so and we bought other things too uh
masks goggles
anything we could get our hands on that
could you know protect us from this
right and what about fresh food i mean
you fruit and vegetables you can't
those don't last forever so do you
expect to get
deliveries too in addition to what you
bought at the store personally
you know that actually we were
originally only going to rely on
deliveries that was my girlfriend's
point she said hey it's too dangerous to
go to the store
let's just rely on deliveries we got a
couple deliveries at first and
everything was okay but these past few
days
no deliveries have came and that's
actually my biggest fear right now is
not the virus but
the deliveries aren't coming through and
there's always the possibility of food
shortages when you have a city of
now six million because of chinese new
year six million people
and we're quarantined so i'm more
worried about food shortages right
now than the virus to be honest um talk
about quarantine as you say you only go
out to walk
chubby so yeah how
when you walk around is it desolate is
it like a ghost town
are there people when you see people
you know what they have in their hands
you can guess
bags stuffed to the top you know packed
with
food anything they're wearing masks
they're just bringing
supplies home from the market or from
wherever when you see people out people
are just going out to get things and
come back
uh so that that's that's unnerving too
are there cars driving around
are you just walking there are some cars
but actually the chinese government has
uh i mean wuhan government has uh
banned all cars unless you have a permit
for special purposes like if one of your
family members is sick can you
get them to them at the hospital or if
you're in um
or if you work for a supermarket if
you're in certain industries then maybe
you can drive but
they're really restricting those permits
so there's very few cars and this is
unnerving because normally the traffic
here is worse than los angeles
i mean there's 11 million people in the
city normally so to see
a couple cars passing by on you know on
a
six lane uh highways
it's unnerving have you seen that movie
28 days later
yes yes it's kind of like that when the
guy wakes up
you know he's in the hospital absolutely
no one at some points in the day it's
just like that
it's a it's it's creepy now those are
like zombie apocalypse movies
this is not that and the question i have
is
is there any civil unrest that you've
seen
anywhere in china well so far
things are okay so far there's there's
enough food
and um people are still very confident
in the response of the government
you know again like i said earlier my
biggest concern is food shortages
and civil unrest not not so much the
virus
the government here has taken a very
very strict very strict
and very proactive uh response to this
uh
to this coronavirus so it wouldn't
it wouldn't surprise me if there are
some you know uh problems in the future
uh especially you know food shortages or
uh
or civil unrest so that keeps me up at
night sometimes i'm not gonna lie to you
doug how long have you been in wuhan why
did you go
i uh i always wanted to go to china i've
been here two years
you know teaching and i came to wuhan
over other cities because the salaries
were actually higher in wuhan than even
in beijing or shanghai so
that's what caught my attention and i
came here i met my girlfriend we fell in
love
stayed here and now this is where we are
that's why i
didn't even consider an evacuation
because i'd have to leave my girlfriend
and my dog
behind they wouldn't be allowed to come
with you no
even if we were married she wouldn't be
allowed to come with me
really so unless she's a u.s citizen or
has a green card
then you know then she could come but
but if you could just be married and not
have a a green card or not be a u.s
citizen so
even then she couldn't be with me even
if we were married so um
and it might be expensive to get
evacuated anyway right
from what i heard and again don't quote
me on this but it's uh the us government
wants you to pay a thousand to be
evacuated
and for me that's not a problem again
over here i've been
you know one thing reason i like it here
i've saved a lot
of money here a lot of money i never
thought this would happen but
now i'm not worried about my financial
situation in this crisis thank god just
have to worry about the virus i can
focus on that
at some point when this is all over with
will you want to come back to the us and
maybe with your girlfriend
and chubby i would love to at some point
and you know
and she has a tourist visa so she can
come by see how she likes it and
you know who knows what will happen who
knows what will happen
well we hope that everything in the end
works out when this is all over with and
and doug
thank you so much for your time and
joining us
all right thank you so much for having
me uh i actually really i've done a lot
of interviews but uh
i really like this one you guys have a
great show thanks a lot
doug perez an american stuck in wuhan
china
in the coronavirus outbreak great to
talk to you
all right take care bye
new from the fox news podcast network my
name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
cal
thomas what's on your mind at the 1980
democratic national convention in new
york senator
ted kennedy delivered a speech following
his defeat by jimmy carter for the
presidential nomination
the speech was boilerplate liberalism
kennedy criticized republicans and
ronald reagan for their ideas
which he said were from the past well
today the past is looking a lot better
than the immediate future under joe
biden and the democrats
a part of his closing line would be good
for today's republicans to consider
following the abbreviated trump era
kennedy said quote
the work goes on the cause endures the
hope still lives
and the dream shall never die unquote
trump has contributed mightily to the
gop
giving the party a backbone it seemed to
have misplaced following the reagan
years
he also has reminded people that
conservative ideas work
including tax cuts a reduction in
regulations and constitutional judges
add to these significant accomplishments
the trump administration's brokering of
four peace deals in the middle east
no one thought possible much less
achievable
and the development of a coronavirus
vaccine various
experts said was not possible by the end
of the year
as trump leaves office where will
republicans go in 2024
the president has hinted he may run
again in four years
if he wins he and his supporters could
enjoy sweet revenge
but should he be a candidate as much as
he has done for the party in the country
should republicans put all their faith
and trust in him
a lot could depend on how
president-elect joe biden does in office
bryden almost certainly will not seek a
second term when he's 82.
last august trump was questioned at a
white house press briefing about polls
showing his popularity was declining
asked to explain he responded quote
nobody likes me
it can only be my personality that's all
unquote
it was a rare moment of transparency for
him
there's still a remnant of old-fashioned
values my grandparents generation
embraced and tried to instill in their
descendants
one was not to belittle demean talk down
to or call other people names
trump has consistently ignored that
advice while a large number of americans
still support him
and the number who voted for him far
outpaced any other republican
presidential candidate
or incumbent president it wasn't enough
the reason can only be
his personality most americans expect a
certain amount of dignity emanating from
one who temporarily holds our highest
office
could trump have achieved all he has
without the name calling
i think so at a minimum he might have
resurrected a quote from a man
who knew plenty about enemies all of
them domestic
i've referenced abraham lincoln's first
inaugural address before but it's worth
remembering even memorizing
at the dawn of the civil war lincoln
said quote we are not enemies but
friends we must not be enemies
though passion may have strained it must
not break our bonds of affection
the mystic courts of memory will swell
when again touched as surely they will
be
by the better angels of our nature
unquote
could such an attitude have delivered a
second term for president trump
it might have swung enough votes to him
from people who place a high value on
deportment
republicans can continue to embrace
trump's policies while getting behind
someone without his baggage
who might that be my view of the perfect
candidate is vice president mike pence
who's been loyal to the president
without the name calling while
preserving his own personality
dignity christian faith and kindness
republicans could do a lot worse than
pence
but not much better i'm cal thomas
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa
just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it
on demand from fox news and amazon alexa
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes